So far, we've been talking about taking
over part of the user's home screen
with widgets.
Meaning that they trade their
precious home screen space for
more information from Sunshine.
A useful trade off for me, and maybe for
many others but there's another element
on the home screen we haven't looked at,
the background of the home screen,
called the wallpaper.
Could we use the wallpaper as a passive
way to bring weather information
to the user?
Yes, we can.
Now, the type of information
we can provide for
wallpaper is somewhat
different from a widget.
Colored icons and text don't exactly
scream most beautiful background ever to
me but what we can do is make beautiful
backgrounds into the weather.
A sunny picture for a sunny day,
a snowy picture for wintertime fun,
and some ominous rain clouds for
when an umbrella's a good idea.
Sounds neat but
how would you actually do it?
What about pictures that are too bright,
making the text or icons hard to read?
How can we build something like
this without becoming an expert
on dynamically changing wallpapers?
Sometimes, you do have
to become an expert but
just as many times, some good Google
fu might reveal the perfect library or
the perfect app that makes
your job much, much easier.
It just so happens,
this is one of those cases.
There's already a live wallpaper
app out there called Muzei
that provides an extensible
system Sunshine can plug into
to build our dynamic weather wallpapers.
So how does that even work?